many people ask how common is fraud in
the world of initial coin offerings
my answer is
it's very common in fact i think it's
quite pervasive the wall street journal
did a very interesting analysis of
1450 icos where they're able to get
white papers
white papers are the documents that icos
distribute on the internet to try to
persuade people to send crypto into
their accounts
the way you buy an ico is you don't go
into the bank and say here's a check for
a thousand dollars i'd like a thousand
dollars worth of the ico rather you send
typically bitcoin or ether to the
promoter of the ico and in return they
give you back crypto which represents
the thing that is going to be the value
in the system that is still to be built
well the wall street journal analyzed
1450 of these these white papers and
they found some fascinating things
they found for example that in 111 of
these icos
entire segments
of the white paper were plagiarized from
other segments of the white paper
they view that as an indicator of fraud
and i agree
but it's also a very intelligent
indicator of fraud
because if you have an ico
that effectively raised 20 30 million
dollars from people and you want to run
an ico yourself
why not copy a successful ico in order
to help commit the fraud that you're
going to commit
so this is
rational plagiarization from that
perspective
they also found that 121 of these icos
there was no disclosure of who the
employees were who the founders were or
there was disclosure of people who
didn't exist they made up phantom people
and they borrowed pictures from stock
locations on the internet or in some
situations they said that it was backed
by certain people you contact the people
and they say never heard of it all right
have no idea what's going on
a third red flag of fraud that the wall
street journal looked at was whether
there was a functioning website
you would think that if you're raising
money in order to do an ico you would
have a functioning website in
conjunction with your ico
well in at least 48 cases the wall
street journal found
no website
in addition in 25 cases the wall street
journal found that there was a
guaranteed financial return
if there's one thing that you know in
the world of securities and securities
offerings you don't guarantee people
financial returns so i think the journal
rationally took this as a hallmark of
fraud
in addition i think the journal's
analysis was
quite modest
because they didn't point out the fact
that all of these initial coin offerings
were not registered with securities
exchange commission
if the sec is correct and i think it is
that in each one of these situations
these initial coin offerings involve the
unregistered sale of securities what the
wall street journal found was 1
450 instances
of violations of the federal securities
laws
and there's a very interesting thing
here
even if there's no fraud in these 1450
situations
the failure to register gives rise to
legal liability on the part of the
organization
selling the initial coins
the federal securities laws
as a penalty for the failure to register
securities that should have been
registered create something that's known
as the recision right
or the registration put
what that means is
if you buy in an initial coin offering
and the offering should have been
registered but it wasn't
you have the right to go back to the
seller
and to say here are my coins i am
returning my coins i want my initial
purchase right back so in other words
there is the right to return the coin
and get your cash back for a year after
the transaction if it should have been
registered but it wasn't
but as a practical matter if the seller
is in minsk
you're not going to go to minsk
and the seller's going to look at you
and go who are you
and the money is in bitcoin and it's not
coming back
another indication of the level of fraud
over here
researchers at university of
pennsylvania conducted a fascinating
analysis that took a tremendous amount
of elbow grease
what they did is they read the white
papers for the 50 largest icos
in 2017
they then actually looked at the code
associated with the coins that were
going to be sold
and what they asked
is how frequently did the coins actually
reflect the promises that were being
made in the white paper
in other words
were you delivering to me
code that accurately reflected the
promises that you made in the white
paper
in 40 out of these 50 situations they
found major major discrepancies
between the promises or the descriptions
in the white paper and the actual coding
of the tokens and coins
so that means that in 80
of the largest icos
in
2017
we have a discrepancy
that is not inconsistent
with the notion of fraud
you promised me something
you gave me something quite different
in each one of these situations
according to this research
the purchasers didn't get something that
was promised to them in the white paper
other than that there are absolutely no
problems in this sector